Lithium der Stoff für die Verkehrswende
er stammt meistens aus Südamerika oder
Australien weiterverarbeitet in China
Deutschland ist abhängig von diesem
Weltmarkt Stefan Müller sieht diese
Entwicklung mit Sorge er finanziert
weltweit rohstoffprojekte wenn man sich
den weltweiten lithiummarkt anschaut
gibt es ungefähr 50 Player auf dieser
Welt die irgendwie miteinander verbunden
sind auf dieser Karte ist kein einziges
deutsches Unternehmen wenn man
zusammenfasst ist das China China China
China Australien Australien USA USA kein
einziges deutsches Unternehmen keine VW
keine BASF keine Siemens keine Mercedes
niemand
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz will das
ändern im Frühjahr war er mit einer
Wirtschaftsdelegation in Südamerika um
den Zugang zu kritischen Rohstoffen zu
sichern
Deutschland will unter anderem eine
Partnerschaft mit Chile in der Atacama
Wüste werden bereits riesige Menge
Lithium gefördert doch der Abbau ist
wasserintensiv und schädigt die Umwelt
Deutschland bietet an die Rohstoffe
umweltfreundlicher zu fördern
wir wollen viele auf seinem Weg zu einem
nachhaltigen Bergbau gerne unterstützen
deshalb haben wir unsere
rohstoffpartnerschaft nicht nur erneuert
sondern ausgeweitet und auch ergänzt
eben um Aspekte der Nachhaltigkeit doch
Chile will die Kontrolle über seine
Rohstoffe behalten und neben Deutschland
Bulle noch andere Länder um den
begehrten Rohstoff
die Tatsache dass gerade aus Chile herr
Scholz ohne irgendwas in den Händen
zurückgekommen ist lässt mich nicht
optimistischer denken darüber dass wir
uns Zugriff auf dieses Projekt sichern
können eine Alternative könnte sein
Lithium Vorkommen in Deutschland und
Europa zu erschließen diese könnten nach
Expertenschätzungen rund 30% des
hiesigen Bedarfs decken
ein Geothermie-Kraftwerk in der Nähe von
Karlsruhe wir treffen Horst Kräuter er
hat große Pläne bislang wurde dieses
Werk genutzt um mit Thermalwasser aus
dem Untergrund Erdwärme zu erzeugen das
heiße Wasser im Oberen Graben enthält
aber auch Lithium Horst Kräuter will
deshalb das Leichtmetall herausfiltern
eine technische Neuheit
da sind wir sehr gut vorangekommen so
weit dass wir im Sommer diesen Jahres
eine Demonstrationsanlage aufbauen die
ungefähr 500 mal größer ist als die
Pilotanlage und dann ab Ende 25 wollen
wir in den kommerziellen Betrieb mit
einer ersten Anlage einsteigen und das
australische Unternehmen will an
mehreren Standorten entlang des Rheins
zunächst 24.000 Tonnen Lithiumhydroxid
im Jahr fördern die Menge würde reichen
für mehr als eine halbe Million
Elektroautos
Valentin Goldberg untersucht Lithium
Vorkommen in Deutschland er bezweifelt
ob in so nahe Zukunft so große Mengen
Lithium aus thermalen tiefenwässern
gefördert werden können
das wird seit 50 Jahren mittlerweile an
diesem Ansatz der lithiumgewinnung aus
Tamaris ein geforscht bisher ist es aber
noch niemandem gelungen eine
industrielle Anlage zu entwickeln einen
Hauptfaktor war aber in der Hinsicht das
einfach der Marktpreis von Lithium zu
niedrig war dass keine wirtschaftliche
Produktion möglich war immerhin hat sich
der Preis für das Leichtmetall in zwei
Jahren mehr als verdreifacht künftig
könnte es sich also lohnen in
Deutschland zu fördern nicht nur am
Oberrheingraben
Probebohrungen des britischen
Unternehmens Zinnwald Lithium südlich
von Dresden Sachsen ist eine Region mit
Bergbautradition das Gestein enthält
Lithium auch hier war die Förderung
bislang nicht rentabel
die Technik zu lithium-gewinnung aus
Gestein ist der Probst das Unternehmen
könnte nach erfolgreichen testbuchungen
sofort loslegen
wir begrüßen es dass das
Genehmigungsverfahren läuft aber es ist
kompliziert und langwierig wir hoffen
sehr dass es beschleunigt werden kann
denn wir wollen mit der Produktion Ende
2026 Anfang 2017 starten
Bürgermeister Markus Wiesenberg
unterstützt eine Wiederansiedlung des
Bergbaus grundsätzlich er befürchtet
aber dass die Umwelt Schaden nehmen
könnte
praktisch haben wir nach der Bergbauzeit
jetzt 30 Jahre lang den Tourismus
aufgebaut und das darf nie kaputt
gemacht werden durch Bergbau ist also
das muss halt wirklich so sein dass der
Bergbau unter Tage ist und das auch der
Abtransport vom Lithium und von dem
schlechten Gestein unter Tage passiert
damit die Einwohner und Touristen
oberirdisch nie viel mitbekommen
zurück im Oberrheingraben auch hier gibt
es Befürchtungen dass die
lithium-gewinnung durch Geothermie
Schäden verursacht wie in
baden-württembergischen Rheinau 4 Jahre
ist es her dass Wolfgang Ernst eine böse
Überraschung erlebte
richtig gezittert irgendwie was ist denn
das hier warum bekommen wir jetzt die
ganze Weser her und da haben wir
eigentlich erstmal mitbekommen dass mir
Erdbeben die Erdbeben waren Folge von
Geothermiebohrungen in 8 km Entfernung
das Unternehmen hatte nicht sachgemäß
gearbeitet die Folge fast 4000 Gebäude
wurden in der Region beschädigt
für die lithium-gewinnung sollen nun
etliche neue geothermie-werke betrieben
werden die Bewohner befürchten weitere
Erdbeben
ich bin jetzt nicht direkt gegen
aber die Schädel sollte von der Firma
bzw für eine Versicherungen übernommen
werden und das ist unser statischer
zuständig auf der Deckel drauf zu haben
Horst Kreuter setzt auf Geothermie und
hält das Risiko von Erdbeben für gering
inzwischen hat sich die Technologie
geändert so dass wir sicher sein können
dass wir hier keine seismazität auslösen
werden die an der Oberfläche spürbar
oder sogar Schäden auslösen das können
wir verhindern die lithium-förderung in
Deutschland hängt an internationalen
Startup Firmen weder die deutsche
Industrie noch die deutsche Politik
haben sich lange Zeit dafür interessiert
wir haben den Zug bis jetzt verschlafen
und das Problem an der Sache ist anders
als die berühmte Garage die man zu
Gründung eines software-unternehmens
braucht es gibt eben nicht unendlich
viele rohstoffprojekte und selbst wenn
sie was finden die kürzlich in Schweden
brauchen Sie 10 15 Jahre bis es
überhaupt in Produktion geht das heißt
das Lithium was wir in 5 Jahren brauchen
haben wir nicht
Deutschlands ehrgeizige Ziele für eine
Verkehrswende sie können daran scheitern
dass Deutschland den Kampf um das
Lithium fast schon verloren hat